a deal to sell the Weinstein Company is
on hold this morning after the New York
State Attorney General filed a lawsuit
against the studio of her sexual
misconduct Harvey Weinstein and his
brother Bob are also named in the suit
filed yesterday their company is accused
of repeatedly failing to protect its
employees from pervasive sexual
harassment Jericka Duncan shows us
what's behind the legal action Jericka
good morning Liana good morning sources
involved in the deal to sell The
Weinstein Company say it's delayed 24 to
48 hours while they assess the impact of
the lawsuit the lawsuit follows a four
month investigation by the attorney
general's office after numerous women
came forward accusing Weinstein of
sexual harassment and assault among the
allegations Weinstein threatened
employees saying I will kill you and I
will kill your family the lawsuit also
claims Weinstein's assistants had copies
of a document known as the Bible which
detailed how to arrange his sexual
activity some of Weinstein drivers were
allegedly required to keep condoms and
erectile disfunction injections in the
car at all times for him Weinstein's
attorney released a statement Sunday
night saying many of the allegations
against Weinstein are without merit the
AG's office said it sued the weinstein
company in part because the studio may
soon be bought and the state wants to
ensure that victims will be compensated
and employees protected now the
weinstein company board said it's
disappointed the AG felt it necessary to
file a complaint adding many of the
allegations relating to the board are
inaccurate Noora all right Eureka thank
you so much